So for this situation source cognitive architectures selected not
one goal but to.
So this SOAR theory this is called an impasse.
An impasse occurs when the decision maker cannot make a decision
either because not enough knowledge is available or because multiple courses of
action there are being selected and the agent cannot decide among them.
In this case two actions have been selected and
the agent cannot decide between them.
Should the pitch throw a curve ball or a fast ball?
At this point SOAR will attempt to learn a rule that might break the impasse.
If the decision maker has a choice between the fast ball and
the curve ball and it cannot decide it,
might there be a way of learning a rule that decides between what to
throw in a particular situation given the choice of the fast falling curve ball.
For this now SOAR will invoke episodic knowledge.
Let's see how SOAR does that and
how it can help SOAR learn the rule that results in the breaking of the impasse.
So imagine that SOAR had episodic knowledge about the previous event,
about the previous instance of an event.
And this previous instance of an event in another game
it was a fifth inning bottom of the fifth inning, if the weather was windy it
was the same batter though, Parra, who bats left handed.
It was a similar kind of situation and the pitcher threw a fastball and
Parra hit a homerun out of it.
Now we want to avoid that.
The current pitcher wants to avoid it.
So given this episodic knowledge about this even set occurred earlier,
SOAR has learning mechanism that allows it to
encapsulate knowledge from this event into the form of
a production rule that can be used as part of the procedural knowledge.
And the learned rule is, if two operators are suggested, and
threw a fast ball is one of those operators, and the batter is Parra,
then dismiss throw-fast-ball operator.
This is the process of learning called chunking.
So, chunking is a process, a learning technique that's SOAR uses
to learn rules that can break impasse.
First note, that chunking is triggered when impasse occurs.
In this situation, the impasse is that two rules got activated and
there is no way of resolving between them.
So the impasse imagery tells the process of chunking,
what the goal of chunking is.
Find a rule that can break the impasse.
SOAR now searches for the episodic memory and
finds an event that has some knowledge that may break the impulse.
In particular, it looks like a perceptual current situation that we had in
previous shot.
And compared to the perceptions of previous situations, of the event memory,
the episodic memory, and
find that any information available of the current batter.
If some information is available that tells, SOAR the result of some previous
action that also occurs in the current impasse, then SOAR picks that event.
So now it tries to encapsulate the result of the previous event,
in the form of a rule.
In this case, it wants to avoid the result of a homerun, and
therefore it says dismiss that particular operator.
If it wanted that particular result,
it would have said throw that particular operator.
We said earlier that in cognitive systems, reasoning, learning and
memory are closely connected.
Here is an example of that.
We're dealing with memory, procedural memory, we're dealing with memory that can
deal with procedural knowledge and episodic knowledge.
Dealing with reasoning, decision making.
We're also dealing with learning, chunking.
If you want to learn more about chunking then the reading by
Lehman Leodon Rosenblum, and
the further readings at the end of this lesson gives lot many more details.